[Music]
how do you want to conduct yourself in
in war do you want to kill everybody in
the room and if you do that's a valid
strategy it could help you win that
battle but will it help you win the war
the impact of the whole mosque shooting
seem to be very muted I think really
across the board for America and a big
part of the problem was that very few
people actually saw it it ended up being
on the internet but it was never on
broadcast television this was a
situation where the fighting that had
occurred in that mosque happened the day
before 10:00 insurgents were killed five
were wounded and the five that were
wounded were treated by Marines who took
over that mosque but instead of being
evacuated behind lines they were left
there and the next day one of the
Marines connected to this unit went in
shot four of those men a second time and
shot one of them a third time in front
of my camera when I got into the mosque
you know I was working for MBC at the
time as a freelancer but I was also
keeping an independent blog for myself
and at that time I was also part of the
Fallujah Pool meaning all the footage
that anyone shot got put into a pool and
everyone used it so my footage ended up
really everywhere in the world on the
BBC on al-jazeera Fox News you know
everywhere but it was interesting no one
in America used the full footage they
all used the abbreviated portion where
the actual shooting was blacked out most
of the overseas networks used the full
footage and so Americans didn't get a
chance to see what what happened in
Fallujah in that mosque incident but the
rest of the world did so I use my blog
at that time to write the story again
but to tell all the details that I could
everything that I saw going into that
mosque everything that happened
afterwards but it also provided some
multi-dimensional reporting that
blogging really allows you to do it
allow me to provide a personal viewpoint
of what was going on how I was feeling
while I was covering these things that I
normally wouldn't do in an NBC report
plus have allow me to explain the role
of my profession as a journalist what
we're supposed to do another thing that
you wouldn't do in a straightforward
report and I was able to do all those
things and I think it clarified for a
lot of people what it actually happened
there it created you know this sense of
understanding that had not come across
in the story that we reported for NBC
and it made it clear to me at that point
really the power of the Internet you
know so eventually when I did come back
to America and the opportunity at Yahoo
came about I felt not only was this a
chance to do the kind of reporting that
I had done with my blog but I felt like
I owed the Internet something I felt
like you know this potentially saved my
career it allowed me to tell the story
that I hadn't told on Network News it
was a do-over you don't get many chances
at do-overs
you